you think you know better and so you
spin around in all kinds of things like
video games and going to the bar and
watching all kinds of sports and doing
all kinds of spiritual
seeking and chasing all kinds of
substances and traveling and trying to
get it through sex trying to get it
through money trying to get it through
luxurious objects trying to get it
through the validation of your parents
trying to get it through the validation
of others online you try to get
fulfillment through all of the most
ways imaginable and that is why
you are getting this reflection because
you are running scripts and you
are asking for this reflection to
liberate yourself from those
conditioned scripts so that you can die
into the portal of Christ that is always
there so you can be God in flesh so you
can finally die on this sword for the
collective's transformation into love
light Unity Prosperity abundance you
want it so bad that's why you asked for
this video you want it so bad you seek
everywhere for it but you have to
crucify all of your sense of self you
have to crucify all of the sense of
Separation you have to crucify all of
the conditioning all of it everything
has to to go every single last Speck has
to go everything has to be healed
everything has to be transformed
everything has to be repented all sins
have to be repented all of them there's
no other way there's no other way to a
fulfilling life